yippee-kay-yay beloved it's Jan here and
today I'm talking rampage deleted scenes
and rejected concepts plus an alternate
ending and a post-credits scene we never
got to see if you're new to my channel
and enjoy this be sure to subscribe and
ring the bell to get all my new movie
breakdowns and deleted scenes videos
obviously spoilers ahead for the movie
so take care if you haven't seen it yet
let's kick things off with the original
ending to rampage which was going to
finish on a rather sad note with the
albino silverback George sacrificing
himself to save the day when the movie
star Dwayne Johnson read the original
script his reaction was did I miss
something George can't be dead
speaking to Rolling Stone Johnson
explained that he doesn't like sad
endings because life brings that and I
don't want it in my movies when the
credits roll I want to feel great to try
and win Johnson over the movies
producers took him through all the
reasons they thought the gorillas should
die saying that he would be sacrificing
himself like a brave soldier to save the
world and kill the animals who would
harm humans however Johnson wasn't
impressed and reminded the producers
that they weren't making Saving Private
Ryan but a movie with a crocodile the
size of a football stadium still it took
about two months for the film's
production to resolve the issue and they
eventually settled on a compromise which
you can see in the final movie when
George plays a prank on Johnson's
character Davis by pretending to be dead
I think the fact that Johnson managed to
change the ending to the film speaks the
power that the wrestler turned actor has
in Hollywood in fact it made me think of
Frank Sinatra who started out as a
singer but whose influence in 1950s
Hollywood allowed him to change the
ending of his film young at heart as for
Johnson it's clear he knows his public
and his worth very well indeed he said
that I have a relationship with an
audience around the world the years I've
built a trust with them that they're
gonna come to my movies and feel good so
every once in a while you have to drop
this card which is we need to figure
something out otherwise I'm not gonna do
the movie in the end rampages director
Brad Payton agreed that Johnson's ending
was better and said that the rock
understands the audience and his
relationship with the audience better
than anyone so at the end of rampage
George is still alive but he's too big
to go back to San
diego zoo and as the rock and george
head off you might be thinking that this
is gearing up for a sequel and you'd be
right
in fact Brad Payton actually filmed a
post-credits sequence that was going to
set up a potential rampage - it was a
scene that the director really liked and
it also included a cameo from his
girlfriend's parents however in the end
the filmmakers chose not to include it
as they didn't want to tie down the
storyline of a future sequel at this
stage Payton has said he's hoping the
scene will be included on the blu-ray
and DVD release though something that
fans of the original rampage games might
have missed seeing in the movie was
mutated humans in the games it's
typically human characters who mutate
into the monsters fire experiments
including mutated humans in the story
was initially considered for the movie
those only got as far as the pitch phase
the reason being that director Brad
Payton says he found it hard to relate
to and just couldn't see how it would
work in the final film ultimately he
felt that concept would have turned the
film into something like a werewolf
movie which is not what he wanted
speaking to Bloody Disgusting Payton
said tone is a big thing for me
I want these movies to be fun people use
the word absurd but I also think it's
important to ground them slightly so
that some of the emotion can be real it
seems that for Payton then you tasted
humans was just one step too far for the
crazy movie universe of rampage another
change from the video game was making
George an albino gorilla of rather than
brown as he is in most of the games the
reason for this change was principally
to make sure that George and rampage
felt different to other movies in the
genre such as King Kong and Planet of
the Apes although initially there were
concerns that it might be hard to get
the look of an albino gorilla right and
make him appear badass enough in the end
the filmmakers felt the design twist was
a striking and effective one now in the
last scene after Davis tells George that
he and Naomi Harris's character dr. Kate
Caldwell her friends let's just say that
George asked as that friendship comes
with any benefits at which point Davis
tells George that he should have some
class however while there's no real
romantic scene between Harris and
Thompson's characters in the final movie
one was actually filmed
yes Noemi harris confirmed that a
kissing scene between her and johnson
was cut from the movie
in fact when InStyle asked Harris what
it was like shooting that scene she went
so far as to say that - compared to our
other on-screen kisses the rock has the
best lips in Hollywood so did you enjoy
rampage and what do you think about the
alternate ending and deleted scenes and
would you like to see a rampage sequel
let me know in the comments below plus
you can tweet me at Jan underscore
Gilbert or at Flik city and if you
enjoyed this a thumbs-up is really
appreciated and you can tap here to
check out more great movie deleted
scenes and movie breakdowns thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers